vi voglio raccontare come qualcosa di
piccolo come un gianduiotto possa fare
un'enorme differenza sul meccanismo
complesso come una turbina a gas
ma cosa sono le turbine a gas le turbine
a gas sono una tecnologia vecchia e sono
state inventate a fine ottocento ma sono
ancora utilizzatissime oggi dipendiamo
da una turbina a gas
tutte le volte che prendiamo l'aereo è
la maggior parte delle volte che
carichiamo smartphone accendiamo la luce
quindi è una tecnologia consolidata ma
purtroppo sono consolidati anche alcuni
dei suoi problemi
immaginate di essere uno dei passeggeri
di quell aereo o guardate le foto degli
incidenti
tutte queste foto hanno qualcosa in
comune quegli incidenti sono stati
causati dallo stesso tipo di problema al
motore alla turbina è la stessa cosa
vale per le turbine che sono nelle
centrali per la produzione di energia
elettrica in quel caso le conseguenze
più gravi sono black out ad esempio con
tutti i disagi che ne conseguono
viene quindi da chiedersi quali siano
questi problemi perché si rompono dovete
sapere che le turbine devono funzionare
in maniera continuativa per tantissimo
tempo e alla lunga possono cedere morire
per fatica per capire cosa sia la fatica
noi abbiamo innanzitutto come fatta una
turbina la turbina è fatta da una serie
di dischi paletta t e dico collettati
perché ciascun disco come delle
protuberanze pronubo dei petali che si
chiamano punto palette e quando il gas
passa attraverso la turbina fa
ondeggiare questi i petali le palette se
l'ampiezza di oscillazione troppo grande
sulla superficie delle palette si
formano delle screpolature come delle
buche in termine tecnico e cariche
all'inizio sono invisibili a occhio nudo
non le si vede ma cominciano a crescere
prima lentamente e poi sempre più veloce
e alla fine arriva la rottura che tanto
microscopica non è e che causa tutti
quei problemi che abbiamo visto prima
quindi il segreto per impedire questa
rottura è semplicemente faresti che
quelle palette non si agitino così tanto
una delle possibili soluzioni e il mio
gianduiotto non è un gianduiotto
semplicemente un pezzettino di metallo
in uno qua che per forma e dimensioni
ricorda un po quello del cioccolatino
torinese in realtà si chiama dunter
smorzatore proprio perché smorza
l'ampiezza di vibrazione delle palette
ed è un componente molto semplice
economico se ne montalo parecchi su
ciascuna turbina e poi capire che cosa
fa al dam per alla turbina vi serve solo
una cosa ricordarmi di quando da piccoli
andavate in altalena se ne accorgeva te
che stavate oscillando troppo andando
troppo veloce semplicemente appoggiato
il piede per terra e l'attrito tra la
vostra scarpe il terreno faceva il resto
il dentro fa esattamente la stessa cosa
strega contro la parte inferiore delle
palette e fa sì che l'ampiezza di
vibrazione delle pale non sia così
grande evitando la formazione di quelle
cricche
problema risolto non proprio idem per
non me li sono inventati o sono in giro
già da qualche anno forse perché sono
così semplici
l'atroce alla loro progettazione un po
tre tentativi erano un po sottovalutati
dai progettisti è però col tempo ci si è
accorti che a seconda della forma della
dimensione della massa
l'effetto sulla turbina poteva cambiare
in alcuni casi addirittura peggiorata la
situazione ma non paghiamo solo dagli
effetti negativi
pensiamo anche alle ricadute positive
che è una progettazione più consapevole
potrebbe avere tutti gli anni spendiamo
60 miliardi di dollari infermi
manutentivi nel solo settore
aereonautico questi tag manutentivi
servono se per fare manutenzione ma in
gran parte sono spesi a ispezionare
paletta per paletta se proprio una
persona che ispeziona paletta per
paletta alla ricerca di quelle
fantomatiche cariche perché non si sa se
e quando e dove potranno apparire ma se
io conosco con precisione l'effetto del
tempio sulla mia turbina io posso
stimare la vita operativa della turbina
con più precisione e quindi programmare
la manutenzione solo quando serve senza
andare a discapito della sicurezza
oppure se io ho capito come funziona il
dente allora per una determinata turbina
posso progettare uno che funziona
niente bene che smorza in maniera
veramente efficiente e allora posso
permettermi di fare delle palle un po
meno resistenti un po più snelle perché
tanto 80 sta lavorando bene ma una
paratia snella vuol dire un motore più
leggero e se riusciamo a ridurre anche
solo dell'un per cento il peso di
ciascun autore d'aereo
siamo in grado di abbattere le emissioni
di co2 della quantità che il portogallo
la grecia producono in un anno non è
cosa da poco
bisogna dedicarci sì però parlando di
dedizione
io da piccola non interessavano gli
aerei nelle turbine non me ne fregava
niente io da piccolo volevo fare la
maestra come la mia nonna
però una cosa mi piaceva da capire le
cose quel momento in cui un concetto che
sembra confuso inutile improvvisamente
diventa ovvio è utilissimo nel 2013
dovevo fare la tesi di laurea magistrale
e il mio relatore mi ha proposto come
argomento proprio quello dei dem per gli
dico la verità di primo acchito non è
molto appassionante però la prima cosa
che mi ha detto è stata se vuoi
migliorare qualcosa prima devi capire
veramente bene fare uno sforzo per
capire bene come questa cosa funziona e
lì mi ha conquistata mi sono inserita in
un gruppo di ricerca al politecnico di
torino che stava già progettando la
prima macchina al mondo se vogliamo
dedicata allo studio del solo dente
insieme abbiamo terminato la
progettazione l'abbiamo costruita
montata calibrata e infine è utilizzata
per misurare i primi dente e abbiamo
cominciato a capire perché qualcuno
funzionava bene e qualcuno meno bene
siamo poi riusciti a simulare il
comportamento dei denti e a validare
questi modelli numerici contro casi di
provenienza industriale quindi parecchio
realistici ma il vero punto di svolta è
arrivato poco più di un anno e mezzo fa
siamo riusciti a sviluppare uno
strumento di progetto che senza bisogno
di lunghi calcoli o simulazioni riesce a
individuare immediatamente quei dem
perché proprio non funzionano in nessun
caso cosa per nulla o via fino a poco
tempo fa e tale indicazione invece su
quelli che funzioneranno meglio
e un po come se la giuria di xfactor
prima del primo round i provini con
milioni di persone che vogliono provare
avesse a disposizione uno strumento che
permette di distinguere quelli che
arriveranno in finale da quelli che non
passeranno nemmeno il primo turno di
provini
il momento più bello di queste
esperienze è stato forse un anno fa
quando ho presentato questi risultati ha
una conferenza tecnica di settore e alla
fine della presentazione un progettista
di esperienza un signore anziano mi si è
avvicinato e mi ha detto sai qualche
anno fa abbiamo progettato una turbina e
l'abbiamo associato un dumper l'abbiamo
costruita consegnato al committente e
dopo qualche mese questa turbina si è
rotta abbiamo poi capito che era stato
proprio il dem per creare al casinò
avessimo saputo allora quello che ci hai
raccontato tu oggi avremmo scartato quel
dem per in cinque minuti
quindi si può fare innovazione anche se
la tecnologia di base e vecchia al mondo
ci sono tante persone che si dedicano
allo studio di energie alternative
pulite e io sono loro molto grata
dobbiamo esserlo tutti però mentre
aspettiamo la nuova generazione di
motori energia pulita non dobbiamo
trovare scuse per non migliorare il più
possibile quello che abbiamo in mano
oggi e questo vuol dire spendere del
tempo delle risorse nel migliorare
qualcosa che il più potrebbero
considerare un dettaglio forse di poco
conto è sicuramente il mio dem perché un
pezzettino di metallo a forma di
cioccolatino e molto meno figo di una
tesla o di un pannello solare ma non è
meno importante perché se ben sfruttato
può dare dei risultati che non sono
trascurabili e questo è vero in tanti
ambiti non dobbiamo cedere alla
tentazione di aspettare che le cose
intorno a noi cambino
ovviamente sperare in qualcosa di
risolutivo stravolgente di slot come
dire dove gli americani e naturale
giuste anche così che avviene il
progresso quello che ho imparato io con
la mia esperienza che ogni tanto
impegnandosi dove si può è in cose
piccole anche come un gianduiotto la
differenza lo possiamo fare noi
e subito e io questo lato
la gente grazie
[Applauso]